[Music]
[Music]
um
man this is the gayest little microphone
it feels like a
it's all up in your grill oh it feels
like a like a wall like a the weakest
one-armed black kid is trying to give me
a hug
that's what it feels like dude like if
you go like this your black skill is
so like whoa somebody feed this boy
and then bring him back to the hug ring
you know because he ain't ready for
[ __ ] reel two arms this dude ain't
ready hug him with one arm
unfortunately i almost knocked this
young lady up that was from south dakota
and she lived on a reservation yeah and
she like threatened to have the baby
damn how old were you 37
this year it was this year
and she wouldn't even be
cool she wouldn't start to have the baby
dude and i just met her at a motel
yeah this guy want to make fun of my
heck are we going to see
a haircut that's all you got left bro
the [ __ ] is slick chris you look like a
deaf guy that goes to the gym
100 dude we had his kid in our in my
neighborhood named robert
and he was like he thought he was twins
that never got separated right
and so yeah when he would talk he would
say something and then
under his breath he would say it again
say it again
you like that oh it never ended yeah and
it
scared the [ __ ] out of everybody bro and
he could not stop doing it
he kept doing it like an echo yeah
whoa and you'd ask him why he didn't he
said he was there was twins inside him
and one of them never got him that's so
funny i grew up in the south yeah man
i'm from the south anybody else from the
south
heck yeah second place in the civil war
runner-up isaac newton had this theory
of gravity and motion but
uh einstein's the guy who figured out
that time and space is a fabric
oh wow and that gravity bends it like he
just
was this guy was so brilliant he sat in
his office and he was having a thought
experiment
and he imagined the more mass you had
the more you bended this fabric of space
wow
that's [ __ ] crazy that's crazy
imagine didn't go and telling somebody
imagine telling your neighbor that
yeah yeah
larry i like him better yeah i just saw
a guy outside of the dsw
shoes and he uh he's [ __ ] talking
about bending space in time bro
yeah dude he's the best man that's
crazy imagine what he [ __ ] you think he
[ __ ] like awesomely or you think that
was like
he [ __ ] nasty at once really nasty
science ladies
not that they're not attractive science
girls no but i mean you think he was
like
you know like a basic kind of sexual guy
you think he was like doing wild stuff
doing equations he was like let me yeah
one of me just dropped me from 100 feet
in his vagina
you know if you want to do that i wish i
knew
what was that like oh my dad was old man
my dad was uh
70 years old when uh when i was born wow
is that right thank you for laughing at
my daddy
that's right he really was which my mom
was 32 which basically makes me a
product of loose skin and loose morals
[Applause]
here but it was cool though like the
quality time we would spend like after
after i was born my dad had a stroke so
we were both learning to walk at the
same
time we have like we'd have like little
races for cookies you know
and uh and uh we
we play games like catch or dull
and uh and my favorite is dad's sleeping
or is he no longer with us
i remember i got on a school bus one day
and the man didn't even take us to
school he just drove us around
and uh he swear to god and then just
drove us back home eventually what's
wrong with him he didn't say anything
either probably drunk
so what kind of girls do you like oh man
i like all kinds of girls really big
small sleeping
who hasn't uh dated a lazy eye girl for
a little bit
don't laugh man she's a hell of a skeet
shooter
that's my favorite joke man i used to
get mad and get up in the face and go
pull and just watch your eye
that's my favorite joke but
i uh know man i like to date a homeless
lady man cause after the date you could
just drop her off anywhere
but i like i like i like a strong girl
you know i like a
a sturdy gal man uh you know kind of
girl who you know
get into some things you know i mean
these skinny girls man like making love
to a can of pickup sticks you know
i'm serious man it's like making love to
a pillowcase full of deer antlers
i need a freaking sturdy man i need a
girl that's got a little her
you know i need a girl that's got some
runner you know maybe a little decent in
the tank
kind of girl that'll just snatch a goat
off a bridge if she has to
you know this kind of girl that gets
into some things you know what i'm
saying
these skinny girls just don't do it for
me man um you
you do yeah she's got a speech
impediment she does this a lot
if she can cook i will take her
i'm serious i'm serious michael a lot of
women don't cook anymore man
and here's my thoughts true gentlemen
look at us hungry clap you hear that
hunger clap
you hear that hunger clap and here's my
thoughts ladies if god didn't want you
to cook
then why did he naturally put milk and
eggs in your body
ingredients staple ingredients
uh black people don't really
know they don't differentiate between
indoors and outdoors
what do you mean outdoors can be indoors
dude what do you mean outdoors can be
indoors
black person you can put them outdoors
and you put them indoors
same volume levels same speed there's no
inside voice there's no there's zero
inside no edit
when you go indoors well they just don't
i don't i don't believe in like a lot of
structures and
i don't know if i don't want to say
woodwork but i want to say overall that
they the difference between indoors and
outdoors
when it comes to most so incredibly it's
so incredibly vaguely racist
do you think there's more porn stars or
murders in the world
um i think murders you know i actually
know a guy
i shouldn't say this on here but i'm not
going to say any names but i know a guy
who killed someone
and he said and this isn't me saying
this dude i wouldn't do something
like this but he said that it [ __ ]
feels good
and he did say that dude koreans are
full of dreams man
yeah we saw this asian guy could have
been korean he was fell off a building
when he hit the bottom dreams came out
of him bro
by dreams do you mean guts and blood no
i just mean you could just feel the
[ __ ] fragments of ideas
and hope and imagination fly out of his
body i want to thank everybody from
fighter and the kid you know i was a and
that's a podcast where they have this
man who is a
fighter and he got
he got beat up and he got attacked a
couple times and he couldn't fight
anymore
because his brain couldn't handle it he
was on the risk of freaking getting that
you know a brush with that tism and so
his brain
you know told him we got to shut it down
and so he quit fighting and he met up
with this other man who's kind of aging
but he's just
you know a sweet funny guy and he got
strong legs the other guy
and their names are brendan and brian
and the podcast is called the fighter
and the kid
and one of them uses moisturizer and one
of them
needs moisturizer
[Music]
you